[Música]
al rededor de 1.159 después de cristo un
matemático llamado buscara el sabio
bosquejo un diseño para una rueda que
contenía depósitos curvos de mercurio
argumentó que al girar las ruedas el
mercurio fluiría al fondo de cada
depósito dejando un lado de la rueda
perpetuamente más pesado que el otro el
desequilibrio mantendría la rueda
girando para siempre el dibujo de
báscara fue uno de los primeros diseños
de una máquina de movimiento perpetuo un
dispositivo que puede trabajar
indefinidamente sin ninguna fuente de
energía externa
imagina un molino de viento que produce
el viento que necesita para seguir
girando o una bombilla cuyo resplandor
proporcione su propia electricidad
estos dispositivos han cautivado la
imaginación de muchos inventores porque
podrían transformar nuestra relación con
la energía
por ejemplo si pudieras construir una
máquina de movimiento perpetuo que
incluye humanos como parte de su sistema
perfectamente eficiente podría sostener
la vida indefinidamente sólo hay un
problema no funcionan
las ideas para máquinas de movimiento
perpetuo violan una o más leyes
fundamentales de la termodinámica
la rama de la física que describe la
relación entre diferentes formas de
energía
la primera ley de la termodinámica dice
que la energía no puede ser creada o
destruida no puedes sacar más energía de
la que pones eso elimina de inmediato
una máquina de movimiento perpetuo útil
porque una máquina solo podría producir
la misma energía que consume
no quedaría nada para alimentar un
automóvil o cargar un teléfono pero si
sólo se quisiera que la máquina se
mantuviera en movimiento los inventores
han propuesto muchas ideas
varios de éstas han sido variaciones en
la rueda sobre equilibrada de báscara
con bolas rodantes o pesos en brazos
oscilantes
ninguno funciona las partes móviles que
hacen más pesado un lado de la rueda
también desplazan su centro de masa
hacia abajo por debajo del eje con un
centro de masa bajo la rueda solo oscila
hacia adelante y atrás como un péndulo y
se tiene que 'hay de un enfoque
diferente en el siglo 17 a robert boyle
se le ocurrió una idea para una olla de
riego automático
teorizó que la acción capilar la
atracción entre líquidos y superficies
que lleva al agua a través de tubos
delgados podría mantener el ciclo de
agua alrededor de la taza
pero si la acción capilar es tan fuerte
como para superar la gravedad y elevar
el agua también evita que caiga de nuevo
en el recipiente
hay versiones con imanes como este
conjunto de rampas como que la pelota es
impulsada hacia arriba por el imán en la
parte superior cayendo a través del
agujero y repitiendo el ciclo
esta falla porque al igual que la olla
de riego automático el imán simplemente
mantendría la bola en la parte superior
incluso si de alguna manera se mantiene
en movimiento a la fuerza del imán se
degradaría con el tiempo dejando
finalmente de funcionar
para que cada una de estas máquinas se
mantenga en movimiento tendrían que
crear algo de energía adicional para
empujar el sistema más allá de su punto
de parada rompiendo la primera ley de la
termodinámica hay algunas que parecen
seguir adelante pero en realidad
invariablemente resultan estar atrayendo
energía de alguna fuente externa
incluso si los ingenieros pudieran de
alguna manera diseñar una máquina que no
violará la primera ley de la
termodinámica todavía no funcionaría en
el mundo real debido a la segunda ley
la segunda ley de la termodinámica nos
dice que la energía tiende a disiparse a
través de procesos como la fricción
cualquier máquina real tendría partes
móviles o interacciones con moléculas de
aire o líquido que generaría pequeñas
cantidades de fricción y calor incluso
en el vacío
ese calor es la energía que se escapa y
que sigue escapándose reduciendo la
energía disponible para mover el propio
sistema hasta que la máquina se
detendría inevitablemente
hasta ahora estas dos leyes de la
termodinámica han obstaculizado cada
idea de movimiento perpetuo y los sueños
de generación de energía perfectamente
eficiente que implican
sin embargo es difícil decir con certeza
que nunca descubriremos una máquina de
movimiento perpetuo porque todavía hay
mucho que no entendemos del universo
tal vez encontremos nuevas formas
exóticas de materia lo que obligaría a
revisar las leyes de la termodinámica
o tal vez a en movimiento perpetuo en
pequeñas escalas cuánticas
lo que podemos estar razonablemente
seguros es que nunca dejaremos de buscar
por ahora lo único que parece
verdaderamente perpetuo es nuestra
búsqueda
desea seguir conociendo hazañas de la
ingeniería de todo el mundo mire este
vídeo para saber cuál es el motivo de la
famosa inclinación de la torre de pisa y
suscríbase a nuestro canal para conocer
más de ted en español
ah